healthy mind being just to start the day
fresh
with coming into the office leaving any
worries
with you at home say look what do i want
to achieve today
and just walk out the door with just a
clean mind like how would you describe
the beginning of your recruitment career
uh rocky
yeah yeah um
i mean i i didn't know what to expect i
mean i i came
from like a new business background
within technology so i had an
understanding of technology
um but i didn't i didn't know how to put
sort of bums on seats for example
in recruitment um so i had to learn that
from scratch tonight to learn that
really quickly because like i say
um i was uh told i was going to be a dad
about six months into my recruitment
career so it was like i needed to learn
fast
organization is so key and
so if you plan your day and then also
get you know a little a little
whiteboard or notes in your phone or
something like that
but have free things that you want to
achieve for that day
and a client said to me before you know
be open for change
and that was the best piece of advice
that i ever had